- My next guest is a music icon
who came down from the
northern reaches of Alaska
to save our souls and sell over
30 million albums worldwide.
Not too shabby.
This year marks the 25th anniversary
of her 12-time platinum, that's right,
12-time platinum selling
record, "Pieces of You."
Let's say hello to Jewel, everybody!
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Hi.
- Hi, I'm so glad to see
you, you know, virtually.
- Yeah, I know, you look so cute.
Oh my gosh, I love your
whole style right now.
Oh, well it's the 25th
anniversary of your debut album.
I mean, it's rare when
any artist has an album,
like "Pieces of You," you
know, that kind of effect
on pop culture and that
kind of life-changing event
for one human, like that
changed your life, that album.
So how is it looking back on that?
- You know, this album
feels like a magic carpet.
I mean, I don't know how
many words are on it.
Let's say 1,000, 1,000
words changed my life.
1,000 words got me on the
cover of TIME Magazine
for representing hope
and kind of moving grunge
out into a different era.
It was insane what this record did to me
and how it changed my life.
- Yeah, I think though,
it's because you were so,
like just as a fan, it
was just so pure and raw
and honest and not formulaic,
and it was all the things that were like
I feel like really
needed in that time too,
or every time.
But I felt like you were really different,
and that's what really stood out.
And it was beautiful and poetic.
And I don't know, we say
we sang "Foolish Games"
together on your Greatest
Albums Hit, and I,
or your Greatest Hits album, sorry,
and I played it cool,
but my friend that was
with me at the time,
I was like, I freaked out after.
Like I was trying to be
really cool in front of you
and not do what I did with Meryl Streep.
But like I was so excited
that I got to sing on that.
I mean, singing harmony with
you is the coolest thing.
You have the sexiest female voice
I've ever heard in my entire life.
Like it's so cool and
poetic and sexy and sweet.
It's so awesome.
- Well, I remember doing
that duet with you,
and I was just, I mean, I know your range,
and I've been a fan of your
voice and of you as a person,
but hearing you sing in person,
when I'm holding out that long note,
it's the very top of what I have.
It's, that's the roof, that's what I got.
And then you were just
like a good third above it
in your chest voice,
like (imitates singing)
♪ This is how long she can do it ♪
♪ I'm just going to hang out a while ♪
It's amazing.
- I wouldn't, no, I'm
gonna be honest with you.
It took all the air.
I feel like you have
like Celine Dion lungs
and your capacity to hold
out a note is kind of insane.
I was really nervous and
trying to bring my A game.
So I impressed you.